hello everyone and welcome back to the
land Doris a be rapid challenge it's a
match three of the magico Nakamura vs
Magnus cross and sorry about my videos
yesterday I had to go to a party at my
nephews but I I mentioned I will not be
making any videos yesterday and so we're
now going to check what happened in the
third match so whoever wins this one
proceeds to the finals of the indoors
heavy rubber challenge to face Daniel
dubov in the finals in the first match
Magnus is defeated he called three to
zero then in the second match he caught
retaliated by a by a half point margin
he won the sort of by four point margin
he won the first match and then the
first game and then drew the next three
so he took the match and now we have the
second game of the third match so first
game ended in a draw and this is the
second game where he Caro has the white
pieces and it's again quite the game
it's really a very very long period ago
struggle so were it's gonna be a while
since we have a completely new game so
he car opens with E for a like he did in
so many other games against Magnus he 5
9 f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5 the
rule opus is on the board and I
mentioned in I think in the previous
video where we had the Berlin defense
that so many games today that come from
the Berlin are really super interesting
and that it's not like you know in the
old days when you had the Berlin and it
was super boring but here Magnus in
instead goes for a six more fees defense
and we're going to have a a different
kind of game so we're back to a four and
now Knight to f6 so continuing in the
faction of more fees defense we have
castles and now Knight captures on e4 we
have d4 by Hikaru this is the the
standard variation we have b5 Bishop to
b3 and now at d5 defending that night
and e4 and now why just wins back at the
pawn so D captures on e5 and Bishop to
e6 now adding another defender to the d5
pawn we have Quinta e to freeing up the
d1 square for the rook and now Bishop to
e7
now with rook to d1 by Hikaru and now
the rock and queen are on the same file
for you basically what you're doing is
you're preparing
for we have castles and he Karl goes for
c4 right away and this is the most often
played move here this is nothing new so
but be captures Bishop characters enter
now Bishop to c5 as the rook to d1 was
played now the f2 point is weak so
Magnus goes for it with Bishop to e3
defending and here Magnus traits with
characters captures and Queen to b8 now
going after the B to pawn but also now
the Queen is no longer on the edge so
you introduce the threat of D captors on
c4 so Nakamura deals with both threats a
width Bishop to b3 defending the bishop
and the b2 pawn and now tonight's the a5
going after that Bishop with night to d4
by Hikaru now defending in the bishop
and also attacking the bishop on e6 and
here Magnus forces the trade we have c5
pretty much forcing Knight captures on
e6 which Hikaru goes for we have F
captors and e6 and now f3 saying that
your Knight has nowhere to go since all
of these squares are covered
and if you don't want to lose the knife
you have to make room for the night so
here at c4 instead attacking the bishop
and like I said this is all been played
before by some very very strong players
so here we have a trade f captures on e4
c captures and b3 with ECAP person B 5 B
captures an 8 you threatening to pick up
the night here so rook captures an a to
end now as the knight here is under
attack Knight to c4 attacking the Queen
and also there is now a double attack on
the b2 point here so Queen B Queen D for
attacking in defending and now comes
Queen to b3 now putting pressure on the
rook and it's a it's a very dangerous
position but it has been reached before
plenty of times and well you have to be
a little bit careful for example your
rook is under attack if you just move
the rook then you have ideas like rook
to f4
trying to deflect the Queen from the
defense of the rook on d1 and the black
will just gain a lot of activity here so
he Karl goes for the absolute best move
which is Knight to c3
now defense this rook this rook is
nicely defended so it's not a problem
and here usually what players would the
black pieces do here is go
rook ate the c8 and this happened in a
lot of notable games like ye against a
visit for example Carolina against Geary
all of them played look to see it here
but here
Magnus instead goes for the pawn he
plays Knight capture son b2 and attacks
durock here on c1 and the move has never
been played before so it is as of move
23 that we have a completely new game
that's why I said it was a sort of a
long theoretical struggle and now Magnus
tries this idea which was not attempted
before
so the rook is under attack rook the b1
places a double attack on the night here
and now Magnus just moves the Queen to
c4 while attacking Carlos Queen so
offering a trade and if the trade
happens then the knight captures and
everything is fine so Hikaru goes
forward with Queen captures Knight
captures and now D captures on e6
grabbing that pawn and now Magnus
doesn't go for the pawn right away he
instead goes rook to f5 he wants to pick
up the point with the rook and
immediately put a rug behind the passed
pawn so he Carl goes Knight to d5 and
only now Magnus captures that rook
captures on e5 but here he allows Hikaru
a very nice tactic so feel free to pause
the video and try to figure out what
would be good for white here what would
you play here with white well I'll give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations on supporting the tactic
and also if you've noticed the title
there are some background issues at hand
here so for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show
it's a rook captures on a six point
being that if you capture the rook rook
to b8 is checkmate the pawn covers the
f7 Square and the King has nowhere to go
so after this rook captures an a6 move
Magnus goes to rook to e8
puts the other look in front of the
passed pawn and now comes Knights the c7
by nakamura attacking Carlson's rook
also defending the e6 pawn once again
and it's a very interesting position
because if rook to c8 or for example
rook to f8 the game continues however
Magnus played rook to d8 and this now
completely loses the game so once again
I
ask you to pause the video and try to
find the winning move for Nakamura while
I'll give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations
and once again exploiting the issue of
the back rank and for those who just
want to enjoy the show it's rook the c6
rook the c6 with the idea of removing
the defender of the d6 squared that's
the point and you have to move the knife
for example if you defend the knight
then white can just pick it up and after
we capture it a seven just wins the game
d8 square is covered once you move and
then just eat Queen and that's it you
have to capture it and the white is just
up a full night and you could try and
play rook to c6 that kinda try and trap
the knight by taking f7 to travel
tonight but then rook the b7 and you
will be able to easily escape with the
night so it's not a problem
so after this rook to c6 move that
Nakamura played and Magnus of course had
to retreat he played Knights to e3 but
now comes the main move you removed the
defender of the d6 square and now look
the d6 again exploiting the back ranked
weaknesses so this gives he car enough
time to push the pawn all the way to e7
so rook the c8 attacking the knight and
now rook the d7 defending the knight and
now a 7 is coming and there's there's
nothing you can do about it Magnus
played h6 but now e 7 here came to h7
not allowing any work to DA to check IDs
but now comes Luke t1 and after this
rook to e1 move it was in this position
that Magnus Carlsen resigned the game
and the game 2 of their 3rd match goes
to Hikaru who now takes the lead in the
match and the Magnus will have to win at
least one game to get back into the into
the match so here you resign because
there is no defense here whatever you do
just loses let's say you have to make a
move and there aren't all that many
moves you can make let's say you try and
waste a move yet Queen just finishes the
game you're gonna capture the Queen and
after let's say Knight captures rook
will recapture and then just Ruby 3 with
a double attack on the knight you lose
this Knight that's the idea behind rook
to e1 and even if you just trade off the
rooks right away let's say captures
captures you attack you attacking the
rook
then look da just wins it's not a
problem you can either capture here and
then white gets a queen or captures and
then you get a queen into the game and
there is nothing more to be done here if
the knight was here instead of here then
it'd be good because then you'd have
like look to see one checkmate since the
knight from here will be covering the f2
square but you don't so that's that's
too bad for Magnus but yeah yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it
Magnus will now have to win a game to
get back into the match so we'll also
see what happens in the next two games I
would like to thank Abdullah Raja Pierre
Michel
Alex Gama Aires Baruch and will inspires
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the Lynn Doris Abdul rapid challenge
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day